PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
So in this session we're going
to look at Laplace transform.
And we'll start with asking you
to recall the definition that
you saw in class, then to
use the definition to compute
the Laplace transform of the
function 1, exponential a*t,
and the delta function.
For each one of these, give
the domain of definition,
or convergence of the integral.
For the last
question, you're asked
to use the results
of question 2 to give
the Laplace transform of
this linear combination
of functions.
In the last part, you're asked
to compute Laplace transform
of cosine and sine.
So why don't you pause the
video, take a few minutes,
and work through that.
Welcome back.
So let's start with
the definition.
Laplace transform of the
function s was defined
as the integral from 0 minus to
infinity of the function f of t
exponential minus s*t dt.
So note here, the
interval of integration
is 0 minus to infinity.
So using this definition,
we can go ahead
and compute our first
Laplace transform, L of 1.
So I'm just going to
substitute 1 in that integral,
which gives me basically
exponential minus s*t dt,
which is just the integral of
the exponential minus s*t over
minus s from 0
minus to infinity.
And if I expand this,
basically, I end up with 1/s,
the minus reverses the order of
integration, so I start with 0,
which is 1, minus the limit
when T goes to infinity,
of exponential minus s*T.
So here the sign of
s becomes important.
If s was positive,
then this term
would go to 0 as t
goes to infinity.
If s is negative, then
this term diverges,
and so we're not anymore in
the domain of convergence
of the Laplace integral.
But really, s could
be also complex.
So what we're
interested in is really
the sign of the real part of s.
So if the real part
of s is positive,
this term is goes to 0, and
the Laplace transform of 1
is just 1/s.
And if the real part
of s is negative,
then the Laplace diverges.
So the domain of convergence
in which you want to be on
is the one where the real
part of s is positive.
OK.
So let's move to the second one.
The second one is a Laplace
of exponential of a*t.
So we can move a bit
faster now, and just
merge the two exponentials.
Exponential minus 0 to
infinity-- 0 to infinity
of this exponential.
Clearly this is just, again, a
case of exponential integration
between the two bounds.
And here again we're
going to hint a problem
with the domain of
convergence where we need-- so
let me just write these again.
So we're going to
have here a minus--
so we have our a minus s.
So we have the
limit again when T
goes to infinity of exponential
minus s plus a capital
T minus 1.
And here, again, we need
to impose the condition
that the real part
of a minus s be
negative to have the domain of
convergence of the integral.
And then we're left with
the Laplace integral
being 1 over s minus a.
If the real part is positive,
then we have divergence.
So the domain of
convergence of this Laplace
is the one defined by
the real part of a less
than the real part of s.
OK.
So let's do the last one.
The last one is the Laplace
transform of the delta function
that we saw before.
That's 0 minus to infinity
delta exponential minus s*t dt.
So from the previous
recitations,
we saw that on this domain,
from 0 minus to infinity,
the delta is 0 everywhere
except at 0, where it basically
assigned a value of this
function at t equal to 0.
So basically we're just
left with exponential of 0,
which is 1.
And this computation
was really easy,
due to the properties
of the delta function.
So that ends roughly this first
part, except that you can also
notice here that the
domain of convergence
for the Laplace
for delta is all s.
There's no condition.
So the last part,
next question, asked
us to compute the
Laplace transform
of a linear combination
of functions.
So this one is 7 plus
8 exponential 2t plus 9
exponential minus 3t.
So here, as you saw the
Laplace is an integral,
and so the Laplace transform
of this linear combination
of functions is the linear
combination of the Laplace
transform of the
functions individually.
And so we can just rewrite
this as 7 Laplace of 1
plus 8 Laplace of
exponential 2t plus 9 Laplace
of exponential minus 3t.
And here we can see how we
can recycle the results from
the previous part, as we
computed the Laplace transform
of 1, and we computed the
Laplace transform exponential
a*t, which we're going to be
able to apply in these two
cases.
So we can write the
results directly here.
And I'm just going to not
rewrite everything, just
include it.
So the Laplace of 1, we
found it earlier to be 1/s.
The Laplace of exponential
2t we just found here,
and it would be s minus 2.
The Laplace of exponential minus
3t would be s minus minus 3,
so it's s plus 3 with the 9.
And we're done.
So for the last
part, you're asked
to compute the Laplace
transform of cosine and sine,
and you should know
these by heart.
But just a trick
to remember it--
I just want to
remind you, again,
of the linearity and the
fact that you could also
use the Euler formula.
Given what we just
derived, you could also
write this, again due to the
linearity of the integral
as a linear combination
of Laplace of cosine
and sine here.
And we know that Laplace of the
exponential a*t is just what we
computed here.
So that would be
s minus i*omega,
which you can just
rewrite like this.
And then identify
just the real part
with the real part,
the imaginary part
with the imaginary part,
which finishes our problem.
And this is a quick
way of checking
that you have that right.
To give you the Laplace
transforms of cosine and sine.
So that ends the
problem for today.
The key point was just
remembering the definition
of the Laplace
transform, and then
learning how to use it
for different cases,
and identify the
domains of convergence.